Stephanie Christian fresh off her
quarantine she thought she was exposed
she's okay she is the White House press
secretary communications director
Stephanie glad you're okay quick
question for you how how much detail
does the president know about the 1,000
page bill that Steve minuchin guarantees
he'll sign the president has been kept
in form simunition has been on the phone
with him constantly the president has
been very active in this process so he's
well aware of what is in it he's been
pushing for Congress to do the right
thing and get ready to help the American
people so we're really looking forward
to this vote today so that he can sign
it into law well that's good news
Stephanie yesterday when we were talking
about what was going on on Capitol Hill
and we heard this about this bill that
Nancy Pelosi had been talking about the
one Brian's talking about a thousand
pages long and people saw all these
things that had nothing to do with kovat
you know Kennedy Center funding and
student debt loan debt forgiveness and
airline emission standards and stuff
like that when you looked at that at the
White House what was the point of view
of the president regarding that because
it had little to do with the disaster
that's going on right now you know it
was disappointing it was a disappointing
thing that they would try to sneak some
things in there when when this is right
now the focus it's all hands on deck
truly and the focus is to to get money
to the American people to get you know
loans to small businesses I was very
very disappointing but again I'm glad
that they were able to work so late into
the evening and looks like we're gonna
have something good and we're gonna be
able to take care of the people of this
country so yesterday you know well every
day the president's had this briefing
Andrew Cuomo the governor of New York
has had a briefing and yesterday this is
what the governor of New York said we
need the federal help and we need the
federal help now different regions have
different curves of the infection New
York is the canary in the coal mine New
York is going first we have the highest
and the fastest rate of infection what
happens to New York
is going to wind up happening to
California and Washington State and
Illinois it's just a matter of time so
Stephanie what's going on between
Governor Cuomo set the record straight
the president's tweeting saying that
they're friends but Cuomo said he needs
30,000 ventilators I know that the Vice
President sent two thousand or the
president in the task force sent 2,000
yesterday they're gonna send two
thousand today but then Governor Cuomo
says will you pick the 26,000 that will
die
what's your response I did hear him say
that and you know New York is the
epicenter right now that is absolutely
the truth but the president has put FEMA
now in charge and they are working to
get supplies to all of the hardest hit
areas New York is certainly going to be
one of them New York is certainly a
priority for this president because it's
one of the hardest hit areas we're
working day and night I've got to say
that with the president's leadership the
Vice President in the task force have
truly been working around the clock to
do everything they can so supplies are
going to start really moving quickly I
would also like to point out that we've
done more tests in the last eight days
then South Korea was able to do in in
eight weeks in South Korea was the gold
standard remember so the president the
task force again working around the
clock I've been watching my colleagues
work day and night to get everything
they can to every state and we're really
we're really looking up and it's gonna
be on the upswing
Stephanie how real is this Easter day
and how well-informed was the rest of
the task force that the president was
going to say that yesterday that his
goal was to open up by Easter you know I
don't know how well inform they were I
think that the president as he has been
doing is very hopeful and wants to have
a message of hope to the American people
I think he would love it if we were
opened up for business yesterday but
after the 15 days when we see the data
come in we'll see where we're at and I
think the president will make his
decision now but he is hopeful and I
will tell you something for as somebody
who was just in quarantine for two weeks
it's tough it's tough and I imagine a
lot of people want to try to get out
there and get back to work as long as
there's social distancing so we'll see
what happens once the 15 days goes past
and we've got new data sets the
president listens to his medical team he
listens
- dr. Burks dr. pouchy he listens to his
task force so I think they'll make some
recommendations and then he'll make
ultimately the final decision right and
dr. foul she said yesterday at the
briefing he said that that particular
time line was aspirational and
flexibility was needed but as you know
Stephanie a couple of days ago
ambassador birx was there and doctor
foul she was not members of the media
went a little crazy like hey wait a
minute you know he said some things he
kind of brushed back at the president
when the president was talking about the
hopeful drug trials is something going
on doctor foul she was asked on you know
what they're trying to do in some
programs and the media and pundits and
stuff like that earlier on mornings on
the mall which is on the radio down
there in Washington listen that is
really unfortunate I would wish that
that would stop because we have a much
bigger problem here than trying to point
out differences they're really
fundamentally at the core when you look
at things there are not differences the
president has listened to what I have
said and what the other people on the
task force have said when I've made
recommendations he's taken them he's
never counted all over written me the
idea of just pitting one against the
other is just not helpful I wish that
would stop what we'd look ahead at the
challenge we have to pull together to
get over this thing
Stephanie why why are there people who
are trying to create a rift or is it as
simple as he's not here today what's
going on you know it's it's more of the
same I think a lot of the media are
wasting an opportunity to get facts out
to the American people that is the
responsibility of the media and right
now it's more vital than ever that they
are trying to do that unfortunately once
again some members of the media are
using a really important time in our
country to try and and divide people on
the task force I couldn't agree with dr.
foul chief more I've sat in meetings
with them the president listens to his
team doctor foul she lays out
recommendations the president asks
questions and he listens to his team
they are in lockstep together he listens
to all of them so it's unfortunate what
the media is doing and I've been I've
been saying all along please use this
time to get factual information to the
American people because I don't think
people at home care if dr. Fuji and the
president get along which they do and
just because sometimes people aren't
there they're out doing work they have a
lot of work to do so we're rotating
people in and out from the task force
Stephanie we're glad to see you back at
work glad that you tested negative thank
you two weeks right yeah two weeks that
was wrong I've got to tell you I feel
great I feel great I'm so grateful to
the doctors who helped take care of me
the president was absolutely supportive
of this but I cannot wait to get back in
that White House and and help out oh
that's great because so many people have
said did you do anything there the
silver lining is we are home with our
families but I guess for you you're so
busy I thought maybe a break would allow
you to take a pause and breathe but I'm
sure you were working from home no yes I
was definitely working from home but
you're kind of blinded you don't you're
not there so it was frustrating I'm very
excited to get to the White House all
right all right Stephanie good luck to
you thank you very much for joining us
we need to get a busy day